Armed conflict in the South China Sea is
certainly unlikely, but it can't be ruled
out. Nationalist sentiment has been
inflamed in China, the Philippines, and
Vietnam, and that can put pressure on
leadership in those countries to act in
provocative and unconstructive ways.
Secondly, severe power imbalances in the
region between China on the one hand and
Southeast Asian states on the other are
not conducive to strategic stability.
Those imbalances make China more likely
to resort to the use of coercion or even
force, especially if Beijing believes
that America's commitment to its
partners in the region is not credible.
And lastly, China has been acting
dangerously and even recklessly in the
South China Sea. It has harassed US
military vessels and aircraft, it has
tried to deny the resupply of Philippine
marines stationed in the South China Sea,
fishing boats have been sunk, and it has
built artificial islands. Thus far, major
incidents have been avoided, cooler heads
have prevailed, but we simply can't count on
that going forward.
Do you think the South China Sea is
worth fighting for?
Let us know in the comments, and also let
us know what other topics you want
AEI scholars to cover in 60 seconds.